Alright, this is just a short video on perfusion index and how we can use it in the EMS or
at hospital setting.
So let's start with a quick overview.
Perfusion index is a measurement that's derived from your SPO2 waveform.
It basically is a ratio of your pulsating or pulsating blood flow to your non pulsating
blood flow.
The values range from very low numbers up to 20%.
In general, a higher value indicates your vasculature is dilated and that you have adequate
pulsatility or good squeeze from the heart and then lower values would indicate that
you have vasoconstriction and or poor pulsatility or poor squeeze.
And this is just a screenshot of a ZOL X series monitor showing where you might see the perfusion
index on your screen.
So the next thing is just in general terms an overview of when we might use the perfusion
index in the EMS or at hospital setting.
So I kind of broke this down into two categories.
First is guiding resuscitation and the next is assessment of pain.
Now I came to this conclusion starting with this narrative review.
So this paper just looked at a bunch of the studies that have been done on using perfusion
index in a clinical setting and they sort of summarized the various uses here in this
next slide.
Of those, I think we can like break them down into two main categories after we eliminate
the ones that aren't relevant in our setting.
So again, that would be guiding resuscitation and assessment of pain.
Now along the way I did find another narrative review which I think is actually a little
more detailed perhaps better than the first one.
So that is shown here.
So if you were looking for one paper to kind of get up to speed on the use of perfusion
index in a clinical setting in general, I think this paper is the place to start.
Now in terms of perfusion index and resuscitation, we can kind of break this down into a couple
different ideas.
So the first is we can use perfusion index to determine whether we need to resuscitate
or not.
We can also evaluate the efficacy of our resuscitation and then specifically we can use a perfusion
index to evaluate fluid responsiveness.
Now I'm not going to get into the details on the specific studies but I'll just show
a couple papers here and these are all linked in the show notes so you can review them on
your own.
So here's one looking at the use of perfusion index in guiding fluid therapy and septic
shock.
Here's another that's describing the use of perfusion index in predicting hypovolemic
shock for trauma patients.
This other one is about perfusion index and the need for vasopressors.
This last one here is about using perfusion index to determine fluid responsiveness.
The next thing we can use perfusion index for is to facilitate the assessment of pain.
So again we won't get into the details here but just a couple studies.
This first one looked at the use of perfusion index for critically ill patients that are
not intubated.
This next one looked at perfusion index as an indicator of pain for patients under general
anesthesia but just to show that the data is not 100% consistent this last paper did
not find any correlation between perfusion index and pain as assessed by an alternative
assessment tool.
So there is some data for using perfusion index both in resuscitation and for pain assessment.
So let's just summarize the objective side of these things.
In general low numbers are not ideal.
Average like what is normal is also a bit elusive maybe in the 1 to 5 range and then
there is an idea that high numbers so over 10 maybe over 15 could be associated with
some sort of pathology or pathophysiology but that's unlikely to be a cause for acute
concern.
For using perfusion index to guide resuscitation consider very low numbers such as under 0.5
to indicate you might need pressors of course along with other resuscitative interventions.
Below 1 or below 1.5 consider resuscitation and then if you have a notable increase in
perfusion index with fluids that may indicate that you can keep repeating that your patient
is fluid responsive.
And then in terms of pain we should see a decreasing perfusion index with an increase
in pain and then an increasing perfusion index with effective analgesia.
So a low perfusion index means we need to give more drugs and a higher perfusion index
means we have adequate analgesia.
And then we do also want to coordinate this with other indicators of pain so normal pain
incidation scales, vital signs that sort of thing.
So that's just a quick overview of perfusion index in a clinical setting but our setting
in the out of hospital world is a little bit different.
So how does perfusion index work in our setting?
So there's one of these papers that we mentioned previously that basically summarized all of
the factors that could contribute to perfusion index being less reliable.
And then I've highlighted all the ones in yellow that apply in our setting.
So if we look at this list we have things like patient positioning, vascular compression,
movement, external lights, etc.
All of this stuff decreases the reliability of perfusion index and it decreases the correlation
between perfusion index as an objective parameter and either pain assessment or evaluating resuscitation.
So if we do choose to use perfusion index in the out of hospital setting we just want
to be cognizant of these things and do what we can to control them.
Okay so let's end with a quick summary.
One thing we didn't mention before is that it's totally fine to use a perfusion index
to verify the accuracy of your SPO2 tracing.
This is one of the initial indications or utilizations of perfusion index.
Moving on from that in general normal is highly variable parameter but maybe in the 1 to 5%
range but trending is probably more valuable over time versus just a single snapshot or
single value.
Low values so less than 0.5 or less than 1 indicate potentially solvable issues.
For example like making sure the measurement is happening correctly, resuscitate, get fluids,
issue pressors, street pain, that sort of thing.
High values so over 10 maybe over 15 are probably fine but may correlate with some sort of hyperdynamic
pathophysiology.
Most of this would be early sepsis, high output, heart failure, unmarked, sympathetic
response and trauma, that sort of thing.
And that's it.
There you have it.
How to use perfusion index in the out of hospital or EMS setting.